welcome to the first academy dialogues
my name is sean finney from the member
relations department
academy dialogue is a new series of
online conversations hosted by the
academy
it begins today with the power of
narrative a conversation between academy
governor whoopi goldberg
and civil rights lawyer brian stevenson
founder and executive director
of the equal justice initiative they'll
be discussing hollywood's historic place
as the purveyor of ethnic and racial
stereotypes
and how the power of narrative can
become the heart of recovery
by addressing racial ethnic and gender
inequities through the stories we choose
to tell now
our first guest needs little
introduction recognized around the world
actor performer activist and co-host of
abc talk show the view
where she guides conversation across
american politics race relations
popular culture and everyday life oscar
emmy grammy and tony award winner and
academy governor
whoopi goldberg hello
our next guest is brian stevenson brian
is a graduate of both harvard law school
and harvard's john f kennedy school of
government
in 1989 he founded the equal justice
initiative and remains
its executive director eji is based in
alabama and focuses on social justice
human rights and criminal justice reform
in the united states
he has argued five cases at the supreme
court in 1-4
his book just mercy a story of justice
and redemption is the basis for the 2019
film just mercy that profiles wrongfully
accused
death row victim walter macmillan
please welcome brian stevenson it's
great to be with you
actually you want to jump in you want to
just jump right into it
let's do it well you know in listening
to
all the things that you've been doing i
want to know just from you
how do you think we got here yeah at
this particular moment
it's a really important question because
i don't think we've done a very good job
in this country of educating people
about the history of america and
um we are a country
that has been corrupted by
a history of racial injustice i believe
we're not really free
because we haven't talked about the
things that have created this
environment we have a history
of racial inequality that is so uh
toxic that you can still feel it and see
it in the air there's a smog in the
atmosphere
and so i believe that we really have to
educate ourselves about the fact that
we're a post-genocide society i think
what happened to native people
when europeans came to this continent
was a genocide we killed
millions of indigenous people through
famine and war and disease but we never
acknowledged that violence we kept their
words half the states in america are
native words
but we made those people leave and we
took their land we created a
constitution that talked about equality
and justice for all but it excluded
these populations and that narrative of
racial difference that we created to
justify that violence
is what then gave rise to two and a half
centuries
of slavery and the thing that i've been
trying to emphasize with people is that
i don't think the true evil of american
slavery
was involuntary servitude and forced
labor i think the real evil of slavery
was the narrative we created that black
people aren't as good as white people
that black people aren't fully human
that black people are less deserving
less evolved less human and that a
terribly destructive
narrative to create for a whole race of
people
and we fight the civil war and the 13th
amendment is passed to end bondage but
it doesn't address
that fundamental narrative that ideology
of white supremacy
because of that i don't think you know
slavery ends in 1865 i think it evolves
and then we see a century of uh
lynching and terrorism and segregation
and racism and racial hierarchy and
we've never really focused on
overcoming that narrative confronting
this ideology of white supremacy dealing
with
the damage created by 400 years
of racist thinking and because we
haven't done that we now live in a
moment
where black and brown people are
presumed dangerous or guilty you can be
a talented
oscar-winning actress or actor but if
you're black you will go
places where you're going to have to
navigate presumptions of dangerousness
and guilt
and that's why so many people are out on
the streets today because when you have
to live like that
yeah no matter how much you've
accomplished no matter what you've done
and how much study you've done
when you still have to go places and be
presumed dangerous and guilty because of
your color
it gets exhausting you get tired and a
lot of us are
feeling the weight of that history that
exhaustion
and we want things to change i think
that's how we got here we got here by
being silent
about our history about ignoring and
denying the past
that is so fundamentally undermined and
compromised
are present and that's why i do believe
this is a moment where we're going to
have to reckon with that history talk
about native genocide talk about slavery
talk about lynching
talk about segregation talk about uh
racial inequality talk about police
violence talk about
narrative failures in hollywood and
entertainment talk about all of these
things
to create a new understanding and a new
under uh new commitment
to what it means to live in a just
society well one of the interesting
things for me
is whenever i watch television as a kid
you know there were narratives that were
there that are you know
they're in me you know because that's
what you saw so you just
assumed why would they lie yeah
you know must have been like this what
was it and then suddenly you start to
learn that secondary history that people
don't talk about
a lot of my friends who are italian have
no idea
that one of the largest lynchings in the
united states of america
was of italians you know the irish
my irish friends they don't have a real
full understanding
that they too were looked upon looked
down upon and if we start talking about
you know the indigenous people here you
know these are all these are all
narratives
that have been shifted and changed and
moved around
and it's why you know adults people my
age
kind of look at things and kind of go
well where am i
yeah where am i in this i think people
older than me probably thought about it
but not the same way you know i love
i love surf movies and i never
we're not even walking past on
we're not anywhere you know and it's
or the the where the boys are well where
were the boys that i was looking for
that's right because we're all going
through the same thing
but it looks like we're not present
that's right
and those narrative choices for me are
really important because
when you when you tell a story like that
when you make a film like that
you're making choices and when you're
excluding whole populations you're
saying something about the worth and
value
of those populations uh you know
throughout the first half of the 20th
century thousands of black people were
pulled out of their homes they were
beaten they were drowned they were
hanged they were tortured
and these lynchings that would sometimes
attract a thousand or
five thousand white people and they
would be happening on the courthouse
lawn and our law enforcement
agencies and the federal government said
nothing and did nothing so when you tell
stories about that era and you don't
talk about that
phenomenon it's almost as if the lives
of black people are irrelevant to the
first half of the 20th century
we made all of these stories in films i
grew up watching these cowboy westerns
and native people were presented as
villains yeah ruthless
they never had full identities and
characters and we were reinforcing this
narrative of racial difference this idea
that native people and indigenous people
they're not like us they're not fully
human they're not to be
valued and that choice gives support to
this history and so now we're having to
reckon with
all of that miseducation
you know there's a there are two statues
one one was in central park one is
outside the capitol in alabama
of this man named marion sims he was a
doctor in medical schools they
frequently referred to him as the father
of gynecology
yeah and what he did in in central
alabama in the 1850s was
experiment on black women he didn't
believe that black people felt pain so
he would actually pull these black women
and start cutting on their bodies and
they would be writhing and screaming in
agony
and and he thought they were pretending
and he made these discoveries about
um about uh the birth process that he
could then use
and and provide some better outcomes for
white women because of those better
outcomes he was hailed as
this medical hero and there's a statue
of him in central park
there's a statue of him in front of the
alabama capital well the truth
is is that he was horrific he tortured
black women he was
uh experimented on black bodies and it
was
completely dishonorable what he did it
cannot honor someone who did something
dishonorable so the statue has come down
in central park
but just a few years ago and our statue
is still outside of our capital when you
begin to understand these histories you
think differently
about what's honorable and we've honored
things in our films and our stories and
in our tv program
that we should have never honored we
should have been more honest about
what those people represented and also
you know
it doesn't help when you have people in
makeup
playing those folks now you know it
and you think to yourself well were
there no
native american you couldn't find
anybody yeah you know
you that jay silverheels didn't no you
know
and to because when you start to tell
the narrative
as it is it it becomes an imbalance
yes because it started out that way
you know it's never been a balanced
playing field not ever
not for americans not for all the asian
folks who came over to work in this kind
it's
never been equal or balanced and
when i look at what's happening now
people are
saying listen you can
tell me who you think your heroes are
but i'm here and been here long enough
to tell you
your heroes may not be my heroes and so
i wanna i want a part of the
conversation
and i think that's what people are doing
and have been doing over the last
you know 10 15 years with cinema
you know people you know want to be
present they want to be
part of the cinema that's happening
without
the the sort of
ideas that people have thrown out from
time to time like you know well if you
have a whole bunch of folks of color in
a movie you know it's not going to sell
overseas
actually they do yes
i'm a perfect example i'm
higher there than here yeah you know
yeah and what people don't appreciate is
it's it's funny because it's such a
misguided notion
uh in world war one when black soldiers
went to
france and germany they were embraced
they were celebrated black veterans got
more recognition
more applause more acknowledgement for
what they did during world war one in
europe than they ever did
in this country when they came back from
world war one wearing their uniforms
they were actually targeted for violence
and we have a report that talks about
the high rate of lynchings of black
veterans after world war one because
white sanders didn't want them to
believe that they were now somebody
because they had fought but their
european experience
actually challenged the idea that they
were less than their white
uh compatriots same thing happens in
world war
ii and throughout the 1950s and 60s
actually black artists would go to
europe because they felt like there was
a space where they could
they could avoid or at least uh minimize
some of the
burdens and barriers so this idea that
you can't tell stories about people of
color
that are going to be embraced or
understood in the international markets
is a very confusing one when you
actually look at the history
of international and european responses
to the black experience and i
i do think it's so important what you
said about the absence of diversity i
mean you could have made those films
about cowboys and indians if you had
real
native uh people on set because they
would be
challenging these portrayals they would
complicate the ease with which
these stories are being told and i think
so much of that would be true
uh for for black people as well and this
is funny because i talk to my friends
and they'll say whenever they see these
stories that are supposed to be about
the experience of women
because i can tell there are no women
involved in that story-making
no women were involved in the creative
process because the story doesn't ring
true
to the lives of women and that's why
diversity
and inclusion is such a critical
component
of how we begin changing these
narratives
you know people talk about diversity but
a lot of times they just want women
and people of color who think and act
just like they do to be in the room
they want a different color to the room
they want a different gender to the room
but they don't want different thinking
yes we are not going to get to the
justice side unless we open our minds
and our hearts to the idea that as
things diversify things change
the thinking is going to change the
conversation is going to change the
storytelling's
going to change is going to be more
authentic and honest and realistic
and informed and that's the power of
diversity at this moment in all sectors
but certainly in the storytelling sector
it's an interesting word diversity yeah
because
people throw it out they say yes you
know we want to be diverse
but i don't know that people really
understand what that
actually means you know because when you
say to someone well
if you had diversity here in your
newsroom someone might have said you
know
we don't need to watch another
eight-minute segment of this man dying
because he's got family you know so
where you have people who are saying
wait wait
we know we're trying to tell this story
but we have now shown this over and over
and over and over and over
so i i need you to figure out another
way
for us to continue to do it it's little
it's little things and i think it's
little things for for women that women
would think of
that a guy just would not yeah
people of color will recognize and see
i've seen that
i i need to do this do we need to do
this differently they're just
little tweaks that people can help make
why do you think why do you think people
are afraid
uh to really have
this conversation what is it that really
is scaring people
yeah i think you know we have practiced
silence for so long
that when people start saying the things
that that
you know haven't been said before it
unnerves people
and i think you know i do think uh
people are afraid we've got
um politicians who have governed uh
through the politics of fear and anger
and uh we've been taught many of us that
if
if
that happens something bad will happen
to you if that happens something bad you
know we got into mass incarceration
in the 1970s because we had politicians
that were preaching fear and anger
uh and they said we need a war on drugs
because people who are drug addicted and
drug dependent they're dangerous
we're going to treat them as criminals
and we could have said that people
dealing with addiction and dependency
have a health problem we need a health
care response we don't have to be afraid
we just have to be
effective but that politics of fear and
anger was very powerful
i think fear and anger are the essential
ingredients of injustice and inequality
and we've done a lot of that in this
country when you look at the history of
slavery
and even the history of what happens to
indigenous or you have to be afraid of
indigenous people native people they'll
kill you you have to be afraid of black
men they'll do all of these terrible
things it was this fear
a full equality that shaped that and
that's why those lynchings were so
powerful and potent
we can't let our children go to school
with black kids because that wouldn't be
safe and healthy
and i think that as we begin now to tell
the truth about this history we have to
just have curse their therapy
it's interesting when you think about
the elements of therapy
whether you're dealing with addiction
alcoholism drug addiction whatever
the first thing you have to do is to be
willing to tell the truth about who you
are
12 steps works only works when you're
prepared to say i'm an alcoholic
i'm an addict and then you begin to tell
the truth of what that means in your
life and that
truth telling is an essential part of
the process
and what we have to have the courage to
have in this country is to admit
that we are a nation shaped by racism
and bigotry
we are a post-genocide society we've
done horrific things we are
slave society we were a society that
perpetrated racial terrorism the black
people
that are in the north and the west are
consequences of this era of terror
between 1900 in 1950 millions of black
people fled the american south and we
haven't acknowledged the fact
that the black people in cleveland in
chicago and detroit and los angeles and
oakland
and new york and boston didn't go to
those communities as
immigrants looking for new economic
opportunities they went to those
communities as refugees and exiles from
terror in the american south and we
haven't talked about it and so
older black people come up to me and
they say mr stevenson i get angry
when i hear somebody say that we're
dealing with domestic terrorism for the
first time in our nation's history after
9 11. they said we go up a terror wait
to worry about being bombed and lynched
and menaced every day of our life
and because we have this fear that if
we're honest about the past
it'll be painful and difficult we try to
avoid it but the reality is is what
every therapeutic intervention that's
effective that i know tells us is that
it's only when we're honest that we get
better it's through truth-telling that
we can actually begin to understand
how to cope with our addictions our
dependency
uh our abuse i mean an abuse senator a
lot of time for first half of the 20th
century said people who are sex abuse
victims and child abuse victims should
never talk about it and that's not
healthy
so i think that's what we have to get
people to understand is that if we have
the courage to tell the truth
i mean i'm from a faith tradition in my
church you know you can't just walk in
and say i want
heaven and all that good stuff i want
all of that redemption and sound
they'll tell you where you first have to
repent you have to confess you cannot be
afraid to tell the truth
of what you've done and who you are
right once you do that on the other side
is redemption and restoration
and uplift and all of these things and
part of what i'm trying to do in our
work is to tell
people i don't want to talk about the
native genocide and slavery and lynching
and segregation
because i want to punish america i want
to talk about these things because i
want to
liberate us i want us to get to
something else
and and i really believe that there's
something better waiting for us i think
there is something
that feels more like freedom that feels
more like a quality that feels more like
justice there are better movies to be
made they're better stories
to be there's a kind of future for this
industry
that energizes all people because it
tells all of those stories but to get
there we're going to have to be honest
about the ways we have failed
the ways we have undermined truth
telling
and then give truth to that and for me
truth and justice is sequential
people want to skip to the
reconciliation skip to the reparation
without telling the truth it doesn't
work like that
it's only when we tell the truth that we
have a consciousness that allows us to
repair the damage to
restore confidence to build healthy
relationships
and i'm going to ask this question and i
i
i hope it's taken in the spirit that i
ask it
what do we need to help people white
people understand because i feel like
white people are very nervous
yeah they're very nervous do we need
to because sometimes i feel like
you should know this i should not
be walking you through this and then i
realized
that unless a lot of this has touched
you in your life
you're not going to be thinking about it
the way that i am you're not going to
notice
where i am not yeah so what
what can we do to help
people who are not people of color who
are not women
who are you know who are white people or
white men how how do we help them
walk through this storm because it is a
storm yeah
yeah well this is where i think actually
hollywood and film
and media have a critical role to play
because
what this industry can do which very few
industries
can do is to invite people into a space
and in a couple of hours tell a story
that radically shifts their thinking
so i and i've seen that just because my
book was turned into a movie
movie came out in january i've gotten
thousands and thousands of emails and
letters from people who were saying
i'm a 57 year old white man i'm a 70
year old i did not understand
the problems that were being created by
a criminal justice and they
desperately now want to do something and
they just saw a movie
and then they want to read a book and
now they want to see other things
you know storytelling is a powerful way
to invite people
into a conversation that wouldn't
ordinarily get there
and we've done it over and over again i
think about domestic violence for
example and your
your question will be about white men is
it's a particularly compelling one
you know we didn't have a healthy
attitude about women who were
experiencing violence in the home
throughout most of the 60s and 70s we
were indifferent to that victimization
we didn't we we blamed people for being
in relationships where they were being
abused
we joked about domestic violence it used
to be a show you remember the
jackie gleason show at the end of that
show
he'd say to the moon alice and everybody
would laugh and that threat of violence
wasn't something that
we saw problematic right and then we
started telling stories that actually
took the perspective of abused women and
farrah fawcett majors made that movie
the burning bed
the role of that and then all of a
sudden people who were being abused
started lifting their voices
and the narrative began to shift and you
could no longer ignore the pain and
anguish and suffering
connected to that kind of violence and
victimization
you know mothers against drunk driving
organized in the 80s to create a new
relationship to driving while drunk
you know we didn't punish people who
were intoxicated while driving we would
pat them
depending on their status we might not
even arrest them or give them a ticket
we didn't
we didn't deal with it but when mothers
against drunk driving started using
narrative to tell painful stories about
the children they lost
uh because of our inability to confront
that problem
the narrative shifted and today you know
we're seeing
uh consequences of that you can be a
celebrity or athlete
if there's a credible allegation of
domestic violence you are going to
be held accountable in ways that you
would not have been held accountable
even 10 years ago and that's a
narrative shift we wouldn't have
marriage equality in this country
if we hadn't started telling stories
that got people who didn't want to hear
about
yes sex relationships to now be in
stories
where that became a part of it and
that's why i think that
that hollywood has a critical role to
play in addressing
uh this long history of silent about
racial inequality this long history of
silence
about racism and bigotry and racial
hierarchy you know i look at the
catalogue of films and stories
that we have about the holocaust which
are so vital we need more of them
because
clearly anti-semitism is still a problem
yeah we have a whole catalog of stories
and i've seen 100 films about that
experience and i want to see more but we
have so few
in the catalog of films and storytelling
about
the brutality of slavery about the era
of lynching
about the pain and suffering of
segregation and and
and i think until we fix that until we
correct that these are american stories
that have never been
told we just put out a report about
reconstruction
in america horrific time between 1865
1876
2000 black people are lynched
lawlessness reigns
the federal government retreats from
helping formerly enslaved people
it's probably the most critical 12-year
period in american history
and you can't count on one hand the
number of
uh committed narratives films stories
programs that have dealt honestly with
that era and until we fix that we're
going to
and i think that's what we can do i
think we can invite reluctant
cautious viewers and people who don't
want to get to step into a space
and then hear some things and see some
things and live through the characters
in ways that get them to
come out on the other side uh now in a
different place i've seen it happen with
just mercy
i saw it happen with the color purple i
remember seeing the color purple
uh in the south and there were people
all around me white viewers who were
very hesitant they were told it was a
great movie but they weren't so sure if
they wanted
and you know there were those scenes and
they were crying just like everybody
else at the end of that film and it
changed their perspective
on what it meant to live in that region
with this population of black people who
were marginalized and excluded and
oppressed
and that's the power of effective
storytelling and that's why i do think
hollywood has a critical role to play
in addressing that very problem that you
i articulate which is how do we get to
people who are very hesitant who are
reluctant
we get to them by going to their spaces
their living rooms
their movie theaters the places where
they consume entertainment
and getting them exposed to these
realities
and is it also making people aware of
you know we have a lot of movies about
american history we have a ton of movies
about american history
but it's only half of the story
it's on the order of the story all of
these
amazing films that people have made from
time and memoriam from the
very first lincoln uh in illinois
to the to the newest lincoln that was
made
this is a a big portion of american
history
but there are other portions of american
history that you also need to know
in order not to recreate
them in real life yeah that is is that a
way to help people
understand that
absolute boys are ours they're not just
black they're not black stories they're
american stories
it's like telling it's like making 50
films about world war ii
and addressing the holocaust it's
incomplete it almost becomes dishonest
to make films about the battles and the
soldiers fighting on the field
and never acknowledge or mention the
holocaust
it's just dishonest and we've done that
in america
with a lot of our storytelling we'll
tell stories about mid 19th century
history
and never talk about slavery or do it in
such a marginal way that it seem as some
peripheral issue and if that's what
you're seeing in the stories you hear
yes they that's what you think we tell
stories about world war one we tell
stories about the first half of the 20th
century
as if we're living in this place where
there isn't all of this terror and
violence going on
and so yes i do think it becomes
dishonest to tell these stories without
being
open to and committed to acknowledging
all the elements of it and i just think
you know again we often time a lot of
storytelling is
what do people want to hear we're only
going to tell the stories that people
want to hear
and that's how we make money is we just
give people what they want
when you look at the film industry we
have actually rejected that
many times i mean we started telling
people started making movies that pushed
back against
the bigotry toward lgbtq people
we started making movies that pushed
back against this idea that women were
just
ornaments in household and and and it
was courageous but it was necessary and
it ultimately was very effective
and very successful and now i actually
think there's a real hunger to
understand the world in which we live
we have to match that appetite with the
kind of storytelling
you know i do think as an advocate i
know i can't go into a courtroom
and just demand things and say i want
this and i believe i've got to go where
people are
yeah but i go there with a mission of
leading them to some place
i think we all need to be that's
healthier
and that's why we're doing a lot of the
work you know that we do we have a
project where we're actually
we have memos that talk about uh white
southerners that were abolitionists that
tried to
slavery we have a memo that talks about
white southerners that were
opposed to lynching and tried to prevent
these evidence of racial terror there
were white people who were actually
working to end
a racial segregation and if i took that
memo and read out some of those names
mostly nobody in the country would know
any of those names
yeah and i'm saying to folks we don't
have to make
false monuments to people who
experimented on black women mercilessly
or people who perpetrated and defended
slavery or people who were
violent misogynists we don't have to
have monuments to them
to have a history that we can be proud
of there are these other people who did
these honorable things and
that's the kind of thing that
storytelling can do you know i
i the film about the the black women who
participated in
uh the nassau launch with john clinton i
mean that
those stories yeah that story was made
and
new characters are introduced to the
american consciousness has a profound
impact on how we think about the lives
of black women and the value that black
women can bring to everything
but without those stories that doesn't
happen and also i
you know we're talking about you know
world war one and world war ii and when
you think about
how many folks of color fought in
both of those wars came home and could
not walk on the sidewalk
i mean for me if you're going to tell us
history of world war ii there are a lot
of people fighting in world war ii there
were a lot of people
who discovered what was going on in nazi
germany
and several of the the black uh
details were the guys who first
walked into places like auschwitz these
this is a story that's never been told
we are
in a way held apart
you know like we weren't we weren't
there we weren't fighting
and i feel like a lot of what
is happening is young folks don't really
know the history because they think of
it as
being something so long ago you know
they they're not aware
of our part in this country
you know or the native americans part in
this country
what these folks did what we did to
fight for a nation
that did not have enough time to show us
a monogram of respect and in fact you
know hung us
because they were mad that we you know
we wearing medals and stuff so those
conversations those
films and those are important and need
to be done
you know they need to be done there's a
a great book called
destined to witness growing up black and
nazi germany
yeah extraordinary book yeah
and we had it for a while and when we
bring it to people people would say well
what's the hook
it's like what what okay
okay you know because it's like if you
don't
if you can't figure out the hook
i don't know how to explain it to you or
you you
want to say hey there's a lot of there's
a lot
to be learned from black performers
you know in the earlier part of the
century there's a lot to be learned
there's a lot to be learned
from native american comics i mean it's
just you know asian comics and
latin comics and you know we're all
here trying to tell these stories and
how do we how do we get these
conversations going
and get past the verbiage that makes it
sound it sounds good but you know they
nothing's to happen yeah yeah yeah but i
yeah i think you're i mean it's so i
mean i think it's really in the richness
of the narrative and you
you've just characterized it so so
wonderfully i mean all of these stories
you have
hundreds of thousands of black people
who go fight for an america that won't
let them
vote that won't let them go through the
front door
that won't respect their basic dignity
they won't pay them fairly but they put
on a uniform
to go fight for that nation with the
hope that if they show
courage and bravery they'll be accepted
and then they come back
and they get to the train station in
some town where
white people will say take that uniform
off uh because you don't deserve to
and they're humiliated by these mobs and
uh we we tell the stories of all of
these black veterans that are lynched
and beaten
and abused because they keep their
uniform on
and there's so much important drama and
important truth-telling and a story like
that
um that we haven't explored we haven't
talked about
you know uh you know you talk about the
native uh
contributions uh the code breakers and
all of that and we'll
hint at it and we'll make a question but
we haven't actually dealt honestly with
that
that legacy as well and i think part of
it is
you know truth can be powerful
overcoming obstacle can be powerful no
matter what your background is
a story about perseverance a story about
people who have courage who stand up
when everybody says sit down who speak
when everybody says be quiet a story
like that can inspire
everybody not just people who are part
of that community
and we haven't actually tapped in uh
to the power of storytelling the power
of inspirational storytelling power of
power you know these incredible stories
by denying or are not allowing ourselves
to tell stories about this community or
that
community or these kinds of difficult
topics and i i just think that's got to
be part of the equation we've got to
have the courage of our convictions
but because hollywood and story
filmmakers
have are responsible for a lot of the
false ideas a lot of the bigotry a lot
of that racial hierarchy
i think we have an obligation to do it
and to be courageous and to push it
and i just think that's got to be part
of the mix too i you know
i you know i came up again my faith
tradition it's you know to whom much is
given much is required uh
you know hollywood this industry has a
has a central platform across the globe
people we all love movies we all love
stories we all love engaging and and we
and that's an opportunity
to do some things and i just think with
that uh
opportunity with all of those resources
and and spaces
we have an obligation to kind of push
some things and i don't think we should
think about it as
as corruptive or anything like i just
think it's truth-telling and we're i'm
seeing these new
sets of stories about uh challenging the
way
uh people in hollywood were targeted
during the mccarthy era
and there's a narrative now about the
victimization that took place
by the excess of government oversight
and that
and once you begin to understand it it
positions you differently
when people start making unfair
judgments about people in this industry
today right and building that
consciousness is how we protect
ourselves from repeating
the sins of the past and i just think we
haven't done that enough
when it comes to racism when it comes to
bias the beautiful thing about
the love all that wonderful uh
storytelling around the holocaust you
know i go to the holocaust museum
i go through it it's so powerful at the
end of it
i'm motivated to say never again yeah i
look for cultural spaces that talk
honestly about the history of slavery
and lynching and segregation and i can't
find them
until we create those spaces and we
create those stories that motivate us at
the end to say
never again can we tolerate this kind of
bigotry we're going to be vulnerable to
the problems that we're seeing today
i mean i and i i'm i look around and i
think
where are the lgbtq stories
where where are those stories which we
need to know
because people know who they are
at when they're little so why aren't we
supporting that and allowing
films to be made that will help young
people through
that will give us some other visual
of the lgbtq community other than
as the comic relief yeah you know
these are these are really important and
i always get in trouble because
people always say well you never include
women i
i do include women but i don't include
all women
you know because for me there was
always someone who was going to win best
actress
always she was always going to be but
hattie mcdaniel was the first one of
color
to win you know and she won best
supporting
but women excelled white women seem to
have had
a an upper hand for the longest time
but even as we look at that as we see
the you know
what we've had to pay for because there
are not a whole bunch
of female directors or producers or
and there should be there should be
given how many women
were working in the 20s 30s 40s
there should be a plethora and there's
not so clearly there's a problem
yeah and i do think this is one of the
things i've been pushing
i think institutions and industries like
the film industry
could gain something making a formal
commitment to truth-telling
so we're going to actually have a period
of time where we're going to create a
process where we're going to just be
honest about the ways
that we failed to confront
racism we've failed to confront um
truth telling right on the experience of
of
lgbtq2p and and you can point to a whole
catalog of films
that really perpetrated a kind of
violence against these communities by
the way they told stories
i think it's worth talking about that i
actually don't think it's a waste of
time
to engage in that kind of reflection and
the barriers that were created
that barred opportunities for women
directors and women producers and bruce
producers and directors of you had to be
so exceptional and so extraordinary to
have any chance at all to direct the
film
if you're if you're a black person or if
you're all of those things are things i
think we can talk about and should talk
about because once we put it all out
there the truth and reconciliation
process in south africa
was critical to that nation's recovery
from apartheid and and victims of
apartheid
could come in and speak what happened to
them and it would be emotional but it
made them
feel differently about the future that
they had that opportunity
yeah and the perpetrators had to speak
to that as well
and rwanda after the genocide they
recognized that they couldn't heal
they didn't create a process for people
to talk honestly about the pain and
suffering of seeing your whole family or
your whole village
slaughtered yeah and then for
perpetrators to give voice to
what was going through their head into
it allowed people to feel
differently i look at germany today and
i wouldn't go to germany
uh if uh they didn't acknowledge the
holocaust if they weren't
committed and you can't go 200 meters in
berlin without seeing markers and stones
that have been placed next to the homes
of jewish families that were abducted
during the holocaust
there's that beautiful holocaust
memorial in the center of berlin and cab
drivers and hotel operators encourage
you to go there
every police officer in germany has to
go to the holocaust sites
every student has to go there are no
adolf hitler statues in germany
it would be unconscionable for someone
so the lag is not there
exactly it's not waving and people
aren't flying over
in fact the swastika is banned yes
nationalist movement that is trying to
emerge there they're using the
confederate flag from america
is their symbol which is but but the
idea that they would have a monument to
them to an archetype of the third it's
so unconscionable but you come to this
country and our landscape is
littered with the iconography of the
defenders and perpetrators of slavery
yeah and that's a function of the truth
telling we have failed
to do and that's that's to me the beauty
of this is that
on the other side of this something
really extraordinary can happen
so they're telling me that we're moments
away from
questions okay which uh
i'm excited to to see
and hear um i'm not sure how that's
going to work
i think sean uh is going to
put questions up that people may have um
are you are you so while i'm waiting for
that
i will ask are you are you optimistic
about the future
truly i am i am and and for me
being hopeful is a necessary element of
this work
you know i i think hopelessness is the
enemy of justice
because when you become hopeless you you
accept things don't fight you don't
tolerate things i think injustice
prevails
where hopelessness persists so for me
it's an orientation it's an obligation
to stay hopeful but i'm
genuinely hopeful because i'm seeing
some things
that i haven't seen before i'm seeing
this broad coalition of people speaking
about these issues i'm seeing companies
uh responding to this even from five
years ago i'm seeing
things that i didn't see in 2015 and
2014
and that encourages me uh but yeah i am
hopeful i
and i live in montgomery alabama and
it's hard to
uh to not be hopeful when you think
about the generation that came before
and you've been here and you've made
that amazing movie about
the boycott but when i think about the
black folks
in this community who did so much more
with so much less a community of people
who didn't have legal institutions to
protect them who didn't
have money to get bail that didn't have
all of these things and yet they would
put on their sunday best
and they would go places and demand the
right to vote
and and fight for the right to be
treated fairly and they knew they'd get
bloodied and battered and beaten but
they went anyway
when i think about the kind of courage
that took i realized that i'm standing
on their shoulders
absolutely standing on their shoulders i
don't have the choice to say this
too hard this is too much i got to give
up i just feel like it is an obligation
you know to keep fighting and so yes i
am hopeful about what we can do and
about what we can achieve in this moment
i just want to keep pushing i want to
make sure it's not a moment
but a movement that we actually begin a
process where
uh you know 12 years from now we can say
look at what we've done over the last 12
years to get to a different place
that's what i'd love to say i'd love to
see a whole catalog of films and stories
and movies 12 years from now that you
and i could point to
this new body of work that has helped us
get people to understand
the challenges that we face well the one
of the great things about
all of this is people are you know
people talk about being woke
i say you may be woke now that's because
we let you sleep
yeah yeah right so now everybody's up
and the key is we have to stay up we
have to stay on top of this and this is
going to be slow going it's not an
easy thing to do but i feel like
people are open to the conversation
they're open to hearing
how can i make it better what i need to
change the name of the team
yes you do yes no yes you do
seeing that was like okay something
clearly
is happening that's right because it's
always been clear to some of us that
that's an offensive name
but that's good but it doesn't
yeah but it's nice to hear that they say
they want to stop so
sean i see that you are about to jump on
this
i am here thank you thank you whoopi
and brian both this is such a such an
amazing conversation literally
could listen for hours i want to get to
some of our member questions
okay um the first one is for the both of
you
how can we at the academy collect and
present evidence
not just words but actual numbers to the
media financiers
that films with black brown lgbtq
casting stories do not inhibit good box
office
well it seems to me you just have to you
have to show people
i mean you know you you have enough
evidence
that people are interested in these
stories because they are the story
they're the universal stories
these are not specific to america these
are not just
american stories these are stories that
exist
everywhere in the world and you put
everything else out i don't know why you
wouldn't
take a shot on some of these stories
no no no i just i mean as a it's
something of a bit of an outsider on
this i
am struck by why there has to be
this higher burden of proof when it
comes to uh the value
of these other stories i mean why you
know black panther made
more money than any marvel film
uh before it it smashed records it was
an
international hit and yet there's still
this skepticism because people
they just have a hard time reconciling
themselves with this
reality the the films that have had
critical success
films like moonlight films like 12 years
of slave
are are stories that ordinarily you'd
see a lot of people trying to replicate
that because they want that same
critical success
yeah but that same kind of financial
success but it's almost as if
uh you know the industry sometimes says
oh well we did black panther so we don't
have to do anything again for another
five or ten years or we did that
and i think that has that's really the
problem i don't think it's a finance
proof number as much as it's an
orientation number
these are american stories if we want to
tell the story of america we have to
tell
all of these stories and there's never
been a shortage or an unwillingness to
tell
the an american story but we just have
to now open that
that lens and uh i mean i think the data
is there
uh but more than the data i just think
there has to be an orientation that
these
stories have value yes they have value
at the box office but they have even
broader value beyond that
and can i add something to that because
it would also be helpful
if people recognize who is inhabiting
the world it's not like we're not
everywhere
you know we are all over the world you
know
you'd be surprised to find out how many
different ethnicities that look like
all the ethnicities you see here are
living
all over the world so these stories they
are connected
and you know if we make them we'll know
if they work
and how well they work it's just you got
somebody's got to make the step thank
you both
the next question is do you believe for
the both of you do you believe that it
is more or less
difficult for black or people of color
filmmakers to break into genre
filmmakers example rom-coms horror
sci-fi fantasy action etc
um i i don't know
because i the you know as john peel
you know he seemed to he seemed to make
the movies
he wants to make you know what the
question is is
is there money is anybody are there
giant
vats of money someplace for filmmakers
who want to do that
you know that's i feel that's been a lot
of filmmakers problems
because you know if you go to some of
the bigger places they say well we have
to own everything
you know you don't you're already
in in deep do where before you even
start
because you're just trying to get
somebody to make your movie if
it was as uh prevalent as it seems to be
for so
many other folks i think that would that
would answer that question
better than i could money is what is at
the root of getting stuff made
i feel yeah and can i just add i mean i
actually think when you look at the
history of film
making and storytelling in america
throughout the 20th century
the industry failed to actually invite
voices in to tell complete stories to
tell truthful stories about our
experience
in this country and when you have failed
and you have denied you didn't do what
you were supposed to do
you should want to repair that you
should want to remedy that
and you should actually make it a
commitment to invest in
corrections to that and let that lead
you
i mean you know i just don't think that
we should assume that the
playing field is level now and we're
just going to see
use the same tactics and strategies
we've used before i've been you know in
the 1960s
you know what we've done in this country
when it comes to justice and rights is
like
it's different than what we do in other
areas of the law in law school i had to
study
damages for tort violations and contract
violations corporate
there's trouble damages and punitive
damages we have a very elaborate
construct of what people are obligated
to
pay when they have violated someone's
rights but in the human rights in the
civil rights context
it's almost as if we say all we want to
do is to stop violating their rights
and you don't have to do anything else
and i think that's left us vulnerable to
failing to appreciate our obligations to
do more to repair the damage that we did
i think in 1965
after these states had denied black
people the right to vote for 100 years
states like alabama and mississippi
shouldn't have just been told you can't
do that anymore
i actually think that black people
should have been automatically
registered to vote
in those states i don't think that would
have been wrong it would have been uh
remain
uh repair for the damage that was done i
don't think it would have been wrong to
say to the university of georgia
mississippi you've got to let black kids
who are qualified to attend these
universes attend for free
because you have to do something to
repair the damage that you did
by excluding black people for so long so
this industry
i think is not it would not be wrong for
this industry to say you know we're
going to commit
a percentage of our resources to create
platforms for
black storytellers and producers and
directors and
people of color and people whose voices
have been historically excluded because
we now want to say to the world
that we want to fix the problem that we
helped uh sustain by our silence
and with that kind of orientation we can
make it easier
for directors and producers and
storytellers of color
to have an opportunity to tell their
stories and what we'll get from that are
some amazingly talented
people uh becoming some of our leaders
and some of the
legends that that we all want to be in
these spaces i don't think that's the
wrong orientation i think it could
actually be a healthy orientation for
the industry
that's a great idea too thank you
next question we have two more just
mercy
this is for you brian just mercy
resonates with our experiences with
access to justice
in my homeland kenya how do we get the
critics on board so that they highlight
diverse stories
you know it's interesting i i um
you know i don't i don't know how to do
i think one other thing that was
fascinating to me and i didn't
understand this and whoopi probably had
this experience much more than
i had is that the people who were
judging
the film initially were people who knew
very little about the lived experience
you know it's like you know we played
the film and
and black audiences and white dogs were
responding with such enthusiasm and
you look at the cinema score for a film
like that it's through the roof
uh but but craig's always we've seen
this before and i was like well where
have you seen this
i don't recall any films that actually
taught i i didn't see it before i never
met a lawyer
until i got to harvard law school so a
story of black people just surrounded by
lawyers
that wasn't familiar to me and i think
there is a sort of cynicism
about it i remember when the color
purple came i remember reading a review
in the atlanta constitution by a
well-known reviewer
and what they said well it wasn't they
didn't like parts of the phone they said
it was unfair to the white people
no there were no white heroes in this
they didn't present white
that kind of people that i think we have
to confront
you know the there's a critical
perspective in this country that is
shaped by these same narratives that
we've been talking about during this
conversation
we have to understand that and i think
people need to be called out
i remember writing that was the first
time i ever wrote a letter to a film
critic
it's when uh that i read that review
about the color purple it wasn't fair to
the what as if somehow white people were
doing everything they possibly could in
the first half of the 20th century to
help black people escape the ravages of
gym
of sharecropping and tenant farming if
anything it
it understated multiple ways in which a
white bias and jim crow laws could
create that kind of narrative and i just
think part of it is
shifting who has that platform just like
we need a more diverse
uh community of people making films and
producing films and
and uh starring in films we need a more
diverse platform of people
who are evaluating these films and it
can speak to the
value of this storytelling you know and
i just um
i think that's part of it and i i'm glad
to hear that somebody from
kenya is here because i i do think these
stories are global
you know i've been to africa and seeing
the way in which
access to justice can be a problem in
that society when you
hear a story about how you can overcome
that and maybe succeed that's inspiring
for everybody
i've gotten some beautiful letters from
people in east africa
in response to seeing the film that i
was really moved by and that's the power
of effective storytelling
thank you so much brian and our last
question
is uh we are poor at teaching our
history of discrimination
while doc's documentaries are good or a
good start how do we encourage
filmmakers
to escape creating distorted history or
social views in the name of creative
choice
i'll let you do this one brian
you know it's funny i think there most
filmmakers
don't want to tell them don't want to
present a story
that they know uh is going to be exposed
as false
right so i i was in a movie theater one
time and they had a character
uh in mobile alabama and they visit and
the actors said
i'm going to mobile alabama and the
whole started laughing
and a bunch of people left because they
couldn't trust a film that didn't get
that
right and so if we really want to be
honest if we don't want to expose
ourselves it's just being completely
then i think we have to be willing to
tell the full story
and uh you know i often think
that filmmakers have one kind of viewer
in mind
and it's a certain person of a certain
race of a certain demographic group as
if america is only that person and as
whoopi said we're gonna
you know we're gonna soon be a minority
majority country there will be more
people of color in this country
than there are people who identify as
white and i just think when you step
back and say let me think about how
young kids of color are going to
experience this story or how women are
going to experience this chore
then you begin to understand that these
so-called creative choices
to kind of make it easy and comfortable
for people are things that we should
push back the most
effective films that i've ever seen the
most moving films are the films that at
times made me uncomfortable
because that's what good storytelling
does it actually pushes you it actually
exposes you to things it's not just
something that you take to make you feel
good at night it's sometimes the most
powerful filmmaking
can push you we cannot create more
justice we cannot create an
uh a healthier society if we're
unwilling to do things that are
uncomfortable
and inconvenient and powerful films that
you know i think about films like
schindler's liz at times it's so
uncomfortable and so painful you're
you're worried about what's going to
happen you know great films the
fruitvale station my friend ryan cougars
film
difficult challenging but those are the
kinds of stories that ultimately
stay with you i can remember those
scenes uh even though i saw the film 20
years ago if we want to make
memorable filmmaking that makes a
difference that lasts that endures the
test of time
then we have to be willing to tell the
truth we have to be willing to do the
hard things
even if they're uncomfortable and
inconvenient and i think that ought to
be the norm rather than the exception
and i think
hollywood and the big studios have to
keep reinforcing their interest in that
kind of storytelling by investing in
films
that tell those stories and not just the
simple easy stories
that you can forget about you know an
hour or two after you leave the theater
i also think that it it would behoove
folks who want to tell these stories who
may not be uh
native american or black folks they may
be white people who are just
invested in the story team up with folks
so that we can help
you get them right we can help you
get to the place where you want your
story to be i believe we can do this
as a as a a coalition
you know of artists because
you know that's what we are we're
artists whether we're
hair artists or light artists we are all
artists
in this and together we can make huge
differences
but we've got to cop to the stuff we
don't know
talk about the stuff that really pisses
us off or that we don't understand
and you know listen i'm not perfect i i
know i have all kinds of tendencies to
snap
in my mind when i see somebody and they
become
that so-and-so you know we all have
these tendencies and so we have to fight
through them
and talk about the fact that we have
them and then move forward
i think we can only do it kind of
collectively
i think really yeah
brian and whoopi goldberg thank you both
so much for joining for sharing your
truth your transparency
your light with all of us and to our
members who
have been attending from around the
world uh to the board of governors and
to the incredible academy staff who put
this together this is just the beginning
of what we hope
to be a long lasting fruitful
conversation about change
um thank you for hosting our first
academy dialogues
we are better because the both of you
thank you so very
much thank you